well hello welcome to the first video of
a series of videos I'll be doing on
which we construct them D for 1d for
repertoire this is of course a new thing
for this channel because I only uploaded
permutate Blitz videos so far but people
requested to see some in some other
content so I was thinking that this
would be a good start to to try out
something else on the first video
actually doesn't contain so many
specific suggestions but it's got the
main point of showing on the general
idea if you construct an opening
repertoire especially if this wrapper
twice not based on 1.e4 because there's
um one really big fundamental difference
between one F or repertoires and
repertoires based on other moves um and
this difference mainly is that all
openings other than 1e form
have got huge issues with loose orders
and this is something that you rarely
see in um in one F or openings um for
instance if you look at one leaf or and
now blacks basically choosing the
general path the game is did will take
and then you choose one specific line or
a specific set up or I need to switch
those arrows I don't want to actually
suggest the center counter here but for
instance let's say he plays a c6 the
caro-kann then you'll get a crown and
nothing else
there won't be most likely any
transpositions to let's say on the
French defense or any transposition - to
1e5 this is basically impossible there
are only very few possible
transpositions between different moves
that leg may play so you actually have
to address each move pick out some line
or some some concept and those don't
interfere with each other
so for instance you pick against the
current pound you pick
let's say the advance variation F
against 1e5 you play I don't know the
Italian game then if you got the problem
with the car can you just switch this
line and it doesn't interfere in any way
with what you play against 25 but this
actually doesn't apply to one D for
openings or openings that are similar
for instance not f3 or C for all these
openings have got huge transpositional
issues and once you switch a certain
line you play you always need to check
if this switch somehow has got any
relation to other things you might play
against other setups so one example for
instance let's say you you play one d4
and you want to choose a line against
the Benoni defense and you decide ok
let's try supp for some selective setup
let's go with F for the ship g7 and it
should be 5 check which is actually one
of the the main lines in them and the
modern benoni and one line that um yeah
put black often on scarce black players
away from the opening in general let's
say you like this line you study it
then at some point someone plays e6
against you you go Nadia 3 is playing c5
you go d5 basically all other moves
don't promise much light of a drug don't
promise them any advantage so you go D 5
it takes d6 not c3 and then you suddenly
discover that you've got the benoni
again but with an ad on f3 already of
course you cannot play a form and you're
in a completely different set up and you
need to know something entirely
different here so your knowledge that
you might have gained of f4 is of no
value here so you need to be aware
that's basically every every time you
decide to play Knight f3 at some point
also in this position if you I'm not
sure for what reason but let's say you
you say you want to avoid this this land
Budapest gambit and you you go Nadia 3
and at this point you're already telling
your opponent okay I won't play on F
form against the Kings Indian I won't
play on f4 against the Benoni
I cannot use my F pawn anymore and also
you're very much committing your knight
of course to f3 so there are no lines
possible anymore where you might play
Knight e3 yet eetu at some point or well
not h3 is very rarely a good idea but 92
can be a pretty good idea in some lines
so early decisions here have pretty
far-reaching consequences when it comes
to to choosing choosing lands for
repertoire you basically have to look at
the whole thing and see if all the
pieces fit together so if you for
instance look at them aligned with the
Kings Indian you always have to
check if there are any possible
transposition to Bologna setups let's
say we get we get a regular Kings Indian
jobs okay why to move of course and now
at this point you for instance some
study on f3 castles right place I don't
know let's say B should be 5 or B should
be 3 it doesn't matter much it does
matter but not for this point I'm trying
to make almost d5 of course II 6 and we
winter abalone just why Adam Kings
Indian move order we enter the regular
bin only set up so in this put in this
case for instance of you if you study
this line it was the Kings in Yin you
need to study also this transposition
it's actually the main line against
against this particular on variation but
this also has the benefit that in case
someone comes up with the regular Benoni
let's say we arrive where the smooth
water then you just play a three Bishop
g5 cancels Queen e2 and you get the same
position so sometimes you can address
two openings with one line but you
always need to aware what kind of
position you might get into what kind of
position you on you actually avoid with
each move order um the repertoire I'm I
will present in the next couple of
videos I'm not sure how many videos it
will take I still got them 15 minute
limit on YouTube so I have to UM do one
segments um
the repertoire it's got the basic idea
to present them some some general
concept that fits together well so that
don't there shouldn't be any huge move
order issues like the benoni trick I
just saw I just showed on it it is
mainly focused on building a huge Center
it's very it's very um it's very
Activant and aggressive so it's also not
zone yeah without risk at some point so
the unsound of course all lines are
playable and also played regularly by by
strong players by which I don't
necessarily mean a world class players
they have really some other demands for
the openings they need to be the extra
bit sounder so to say so if you just
play regular people you can take some
more risk than world class players for
instance um okay let's see if I forgot
something yeah one one general point
it's it's not possible of course to to
show all all opening lines rail lines so
I won't I want to address them let's say
I'm d4 d5 for instance on d4 a six or
something of course this is in in some
way playable but I'll focus on the kind
of lines you get if you add it all up in
I don't know 95 97 percent of the games
if you play d4 regularly I also won't go
into lines that are 20 moves deep or
something I'll just show the general
direction and also will point out for
certain lines
where to look further for instance try
to recommend a book if I if I know one
of hand that might help with studying
the specific line or a recommender soul
players which you could could look the
game's up and study the way of these
experts on play them the line in
question um yeah I guess that's it for
the introduction I'm pretty sure that I
will forget one line or another so
please point out and the feedback on
which lines you are missing of course
really not not those completely obscure
stuff so but if I forget one really
important opening just just tell me and
I alone at this um in further and
further videos if you have some specific
interest in our in a certain line I can
also make a dedicated video later this
is I've got the time
okay please leave any questions or
comments um on YouTube and enjoy the
further videos in this series